[Music]  bow down the queen is in the building  introducing this Nutrition Dabrowski aka  patty cake  aka Kenda  Oh gorgeous  [ __ ] where do you see yourself in five  years I hope to still be working for you  sir  your pen game is ridiculous you have  nope it's full of songs feet how bad did  you want this you don't have a musical  bone in your body  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  what's you got singing it way like so we  doing some drops I'm actually going as  cookie  if more talent and imagination unless  this whole town tonight  this is the biggest opportunity of your  life keep your head up killing it's a  cold world out there your puppets  [Music]